ALISON HILL: Welcome,
everyone, to the webinar
on Sharing on Short Notice,
where we'll show you
how to get your teaching
materials online
with R Markdown.
So hello.
We're really happy you
could join us today.
We know that everybody has
a lot of things going on,
so we appreciate you taking the
time to join us this afternoon.
My name is Alison Hill,
and I'm a data scientist
and professional
educator at RStudio.
DESIREE DE LEON:
And I'm Desiree,
and I interned with
Alison last summer
at RStudio on the
education team.
ALISON HILL: And
even though we don't
have a video feed
in this webinar,
we promise we are real-life
humans who are also
stuck at home just
now like you all,
sitting in front
of our computers.
And one thing that Desiree
and I both have in common
is that we ship a
lot of websites.
I'm a developmental
psychologist.
Desiree is a neuroscientist.
Neither of us is
a web developer,
but we both ship
a lot of websites
for teaching data science.
And here are just a few of them.
If you type the short link
on the bottom of our slides,
it's rstd.io/sharing.
You'll be able to see our
slides and follow along
in your browser.
So you can see,
all of these links
are also applicable for you.
Each of these sites
was built using
R Markdown with
different tools chosen
depending on what we needed.
So that's us.
Who are you?
We think you're an
educator, and you
have R Markdown files
that you use for teaching.
But they may be stuck
on your computer
and you need to
share them easily
with others without
filling up their inboxes.
And that's because you
probably have a new classroom
space that looks like this.
So sharing needs to
be done 100% online.
And you might feel
like this right now.
Everything seems to
need your attention,
but you cannot do everything.
So with that in
mind, today we'd like
to give you a quick tour
of the R Markdown tools
that you can use to get
your course materials online
on very short notice.
We'll show you how to
build a course website,
to help you teach
and reach learners
using R Markdown and friends.
And our goal is to
give you a quick boost
to help you get your site up off
the ground with a sharable link
so that you can get
on with your teaching
and hopefully avoid
crashing in the process.
So why make a course
website at all?
I think of it as a way, first to
help me organize my own stuff,
to get all my piles
of teaching documents
into some kind of
order, and then
make some more reproducible
for myself and for others.
But it's also a way to make my
teaching more resilient if I'm
organized and online,
I can be more nimble
when changes need to happen.
And a side benefit of
all that is that it also
makes it more shareable.
So it makes it
easier for learners,
too, because they
see what I see.
So we'll be building
websites with R Markdown.
And because of that, we'll
start by talking about building
a single R Markdown file.
So Desiree, you're up.
DESIREE DE LEON: All right.
Thanks, Alison.
So let's see.
Jumping right in, what does
an R Markdown file look like?
So here's an R project
folder for a lab, let's say.
And inside that folder, you'll
notice an R project file.
And opening that file in
RStudio takes us here,
where we can see our
single R Markdown file.
And as I mentioned,
this is one for a lab
that's going to visualize data
from the Museum of Modern Art.
So let's just quickly
walk through some
of the key parts of this file.
It starts with metadata
written in YAML,
which is a list of
keys on the left
and their values on the right.
And the first key you see is
title, which is, in this case,
Lab 02 MoMA Museum Tour.
And the last section is
all about output in YAML.
So here, the output
is an HTML document.
And beneath that, we can add
options to our HTML document,
for example, a table of contents
with the key toc set to true.
So that's the metadata.
But the real meat in
your R Markdown file
is text written in Markdown, and
of course, code written in R.
So these three things,
metadata, text, and code,
make up an R Markdown document.
ALISON HILL: So of
course, Desiree,
the real magic happens when
you click on the Knit button
and see your file
turned into HTML.
So when we click
on the Knit button,
we can watch the build
happening in the bottom pane.
Our R Markdown document
gets processed,
and you can see the
rendered HTML file locally.
You can also choose to open
it up in a bigger browser
and explore around
by clicking on it,
testing a few things out.
DESIREE DE LEON: OK, so here's
a screenshot of what we just
showed you, what we knit.
And we can see that using
the theme key in our YAML,
we were able to apply changes
to our fonts and colors.
And we have this nice
table of contents that's
floating off to the side.
This is still local and
stuck on my computer.
A link would make it a lot
easier to share with learners.
So how do we start sharing?
First, we need a web
server, which is basically
a big computer in the clouds.
And a hat tip to Heather
Nolis for that analogy.
And for this
webinar, we're going
to use a web server
provided by Netlify.
So we're going to drag and
drop that project folder
into Netlify, and this is going
to put our web page on line.
So Alison, let's go ahead and
do our first drag and drop.
ALISON HILL: Happy to, Desiree.
So I open up my browser,
go to app.netlify.com/drop.
And I type very slow.
And then I'm going to see
that little box where it says,
drag and drop your
site folder here.
I'm going to take
that Lab2 folder
and drag it right into that box.
You can see Netlify
thinks for a second,
and now my site is live.
And it gives me a nice
random link, friendly-borg,
that I can now share
with whomever I choose.
Hurray!
DESIREE DE LEON: All right.
Hurray.
We have deployed to Netlify.
But just a quick summary
of what happened.
So we started with an R Markdown
file, and it was named index.
We knit this to convert it to
a internet-ready HTML file.
That looked great, but it
still only lived locally
in our project folder.
So we had to drag and drop it
into Netlify, which deployed
our page and generated a link.
Woohoo.
OK, but this is just
one R Markdown file,
and we want to be able to
share many R Markdown files.
So we're going to hike
Markdown Mountain today.
And our goal for the
rest of this webinar
is to show you four
R Markdown tools that
are for turning a collection
of R Markdowns into a website.
And we're going to start with
the classic R Markdown site.
So to make one, you just
need the R Markdown package
installed, which is already
done for you if you use RStudio.
And here is an R Markdown
site for a course
about data visualization.
This is just a screenshot.
You can go to the link above it.
And actually, the MoMA lab that
we just turned into a web page
was one of the labs
from this course.
Now, this course
web site is a place
to share all of those labs.
And the biggest addition
that we see here
is a top navigation
bar, which allows
us to link to other web pages
including ones made with R
Markdown, like this page
with slides and readings,
or other websites
like this one here,
which goes to a learning
management system.
All right so.
Let's build a minimal R
Markdown site of our own.
Imagine that this
box on the left
is a list of files that are
inside of our project folder.
And to knit all of these pages
into our R Markdown site,
you can mouse over to
the Build tab in RStudio
and then click Build Website.
And after we've done that,
we see that it's added a new
folder called _site, and that's
where all of our HTML files
live.
And then we can also see the
site we just built locally.
We have a nav bar, a
theme, and in this case,
even a drop-down menu.
So let's look under the
hood at some of these files.
And we'll start with index.Rmd.
Index is a special file
name in any website,
because it always
becomes the home page.
So if each of our R
Markdown files in our site
was a hot-air
balloon here, index
would be the first one you see.
And if we take a peek
inside index.Rmd,
we actually don't see
anything very special.
In fact, you can actually
take any existing R Markdown
document that you already
have, rename it index,
and turn it into
your site's homepage.
The next file is _site.yml.
And this is new.
So this file is in charge
of tying all of the pages
together.
And it's a site configuration
file written in YAML.
And let's take a
look inside of that.
So the first thing
you may notice
is that this is a YAML file,
so there are no fences.
It's just a list
of keys and values.
And the first key
that we see is navbar.
And this is what lets you
build your site's navigation.
There's a key for
title in this site
YAML, and whether we want
our links to be on the left,
but you could also
put them on the right.
And if we want links
listed in a drop-down menu
we can do that too
from this file.
And for all the pages you
link to in your app bar,
there is a key called href that
needs to point to an HTML file,
even though you're using R
Markdown files as your source.
You need to make sure that it's
always going to an HTML file.
And finally, we can set up a
theme that will apply to all
of the pages
throughout our site .
And as for other
R Markdown pages
there is nothing special
about them, either.
As long as you link to a
page in your _site.yml,
you can take any existing
R Markdown file and turn it
into a page in your site.
So a quiz, Alison.
Here is a page that's a
lab page on our website.
What do you think the YAML
for this lab page looks like?
ALISON HILL: Oh, good question.
I think that this YAML has
table of contents, toc, as one
of the keys that's set to true.
And I see it's floating
off to the left,
so I think toc_float
is also set to true.
And I see my favorite
code, download key.
So code_download, I
believe, is true also,
which allows you to click on
that nice little Download Rmd
button, and somebody can
download your source Rmd file.
DESIREE DE LEON: OK,
Alison, good job.
That's exactly what we see.
You can set the YAML for
each page if you want.
It doesn't only have to be
done in the _site.yml file.
And if you want the output
options to apply to every
single page, that's when
you would choose to put it
in the _site.yml file, as
opposed to the individual page.
But OK, so finally we are ready
to share our R Markdown sites.
And we'll do this the
same way as we did before.
As a reminder, all of our HTML
website-ready pages are stored
in this _site folder.
So this is the only folder
that we need to drag and drop.
So Alison, can you
take it away again?
ALISON HILL: I will.
So here we're back at
app.netlify.com/drop,
and we're dropping that
_site folder right in.
And we're able to get a
link, hardcore-goldwasser.
Great name, website.
DESIREE DE LEON: OK, thank you.
So one thing you may have
noticed with what Alison just
showed you is that there is a
note from Netlify, and it says,
unclaimed sites are
deleted after 24 hours.
So we have to actually create
an account with Netlify
to keep our site
online permanently.
So let's actually go back
to Netlify and do that.
ALISON HILL: So we
click on the little Sign
Up for Netlify button,
and you can sign up
with an existing
version control account,
like GitHub, GitLab,
or BitBucket.
So if you have one,
I encourage you
to use those to
sign in to Netlify,
because that'll make
your life easier.
And today, we're going
to actually sign up
with an email address.
So Desiree is entering an
email address, signing up
for an account with Netlify.
She's waiting on instructions
for how to verify her account.
And we have it, and we
will be able to own,
was it hardcore-goldwasser
forever?
[LAUGHTER]
So now it's part of her
team on her Netlify account,
and your silly-named
link is now here to stay.
DESIREE DE LEON: All right.
Great.
OK, but after I've deployed my
site, what happens if I decide
that I want to make a change?
So let's say, for
example, looking
at the YAML file
on the left side,
say that I want to change
my theme to something
named United.
So once I make
that change, I need
to remember to
rebuild my website.
And then I need to be able
to drag and drop again.
So let's see what that
process looks like.
ALISON HILL: Sorry, my
mouse has gone missing.
DESIREE DE LEON: There we go.
OK, so once we've rebuilt our
site with the changes that we
want, we can just use
that _site folder again,
but we have to go into
Deploys in our Netlify UI,
and then you see the little
box, "Need to update your site?
Drag and drop your
site folder here.
So this means that
we get to keep
that link, the
hardcore-goldwasser link,
and update the same link
with our new content.
So if we drag and drop it again
it takes a second to think,
and it republishes.
So now if we click
on the link, we
can see that our new theme, the
United theme, has been applied.
So it looks a little
bit different,
but the link is the same.
Great.
So now you know how to build
and update R Markdown sites.
And before we move
on to the next tool,
I just want to highlight
some good and bad points
to take away about using
this tool for a course.
So some really great things is
that the source stays the same.
You can use a lot of
your existing documents
and just plop them
right in without having
to change much at all.
And another really
great thing is
that you have these
built-in themes
you can take advantage of,
to give your site a makeover
easily.
A bad thing about
R Markdown sites
is that as you start to
add many different pages,
your directory can get really,
really full, because R Markdown
sites do not allow you to
organize pages and R Markdown
documents into sub-folders.
So that's just one
thing to keep in mind.
But with that, let's
go ahead and move on
to our next tool,
which is Distill.
So our next stop on Markdown
Mountain is Distill websites.
And you'll have to
install the Distill
package before you can use it.
And I just want to give you
a quick tour of the Distill
websites.
So let's go ahead
and press Play here.
And the style of a Distill
site is actually not
very easy to change without CSS,
but it looks pretty slick out
of the box.
So you can think of Distill
as being a little bit
like the nerdier sibling
of an R Markdown site.
It's built for much more
technical and scientific
communication.
So for example, there is a
way to list multiple authors
and their affiliations.
You can also include footers and
asides in your Distill pages.
And there's this really nice
way to display reuse licenses
for educational content.
So this is some of the
features in the Distill website
that come out of the box.
And so now let's build a
minimal Distill site of our own.
And just like we did
with the R Markdown site,
we're going to use the Build
tab to knit some files that
are in our project directory.
And once we do that, it's
going to create a folder,
again called _site, that's
going to house our HTML files.
Here is what our minimal Distill
site's going to look like.
And just to point out,
we can add a description.
We can have those
multiple authors.
We can still retain that
drop-down menu that we also
had in R Markdown sites.
So let's look at some of
these files a little bit more
closely, starting
with the index page.
Again, this is going to be our
home page in a Distill website,
and any existing R Markdown
document that you have will do.
There's just one addition we
need to make inside of this
file, and that is that in
the YAML of the index file,
we need to be able to
add this line, site:
distill::distill_website.
And it's also nice to include a
title and a short description,
but not necessary.
And then we also have
an _site.yml file.
This is still going to be
our site configuration,
so this should also
sound a bit familiar.
And the YAML navbar
keys here are
similar to what we used
in R Markdown sites,
with one important change.
The output must
specify that this is
going to be a distill_article.
And there is one more
thing I need to tell you
about Distill websites.
You can make part of
your Distill website
into a blog, which
looks like this.
So essentially, you can
have a single page made up
of clickable posts.
And each post itself
is its own page
and it doesn't need to be
built into the navigation
bar the way that other parts
of R Markdown sites need to be
or like Distill
sites need to be.
And this can be useful in a
classroom setting just if you
want to post different
things like announcements
in a running list sort of way.
So in order to create
a blog-like page,
we first need to create
what's called a listing page.
And this is an R
Markdown document
whose only job is to
have a title and then
a listing, the YAML
key, and value.
And we're going to call
our listing page Schedule.
And then we have to remember
to link this listing page
to the navigation
bar within _site.yml.
And once we've done
that, then we're
ready to make some blog posts.
So the most straightforward
way to create a post is to run
the code distill::create_post.
And then within the parentheses,
you put the title of your post.
And this is automatically going
to create a new folder called
_posts with a subdirectory
for your post.
And it will also
trigger a little window
to open with your R Markdown
file, ready for you to edit.
And you can rinse and
repeat this process,
creating as many new
posts as you'd like.
So let's go ahead and just look
inside one of those post files.
On the left here, you can see
what I mean when I said that it
creates a little subdirectory
for your post underneath
the _posts folder.
And all of this is
created for you,
so you don't really
have to worry
too much about remembering
the order here.
But if we look inside
of the post itself,
we see that the YAML is already
automatically populated for us
with the information
that we need.
We can edit it if we need to
change the date or the title.
And the only downside
here is that once we're
done creating our post,
we have to remember
to knit this post individually.
If you don't knit it
on its own, then it
won't show up on
your listing page.
So once we've created
all of our posts,
we can then remember to build
our website one last time
so that the listing page will
be updated with any posts
that we've created.
And here, for example, is what
our very minimal blog listing
page looks like.
So on the left, you see
what the listing page is,
and then you can click on to
any of those individual links
to see what the post looks like.
And just as before, once
we're ready to share,
we can use our old
drag-and-drop method.
So we'll take the _site folder
and drag that in to Netlify,
just as we did with
R Markdown sites.
So with that, we've covered
two R Markdown tools.
And there's just
a couple of points
I want to highlight
about Distill before we
move on to the next tool.
Really nice things
about Distill are
that you have these really great
design features out of the box.
You have two content flavors.
You can have a regular page.
But you can also have
this blog-like page,
which just lets you show some
more chronological content.
One bad thing about Distill--
it's just pretty
annoying, I guess,
to have to remember to knit
each individual post one by one
if you would like to take
advantage of the blog feature.
But the good thing
there, at least,
is that you don't have to do
anything manual to make sure
that your posts get on that
listing page we created.
OK, so now for the
rest of the tools,
Alison will be our guide for
our ascent up Markdown Mountain.
And we have two
more tools to go.
ALISON HILL: Thank
you, [INAUDIBLE]..
So I'm going to
describe bookdown now,
which is another R package
that you need to install
before being able to use it.
And as the package
name suggests,
bookdown is a way to build
books with R markdown.
And you can use it to build
an online book with a table
of contents, chapters-- in fact,
as many chapters as you want--
and lots of bells
and whistles that we
won't be able to cover today.
But they're all actually
covered in the bookdown
book, which you can see here.
And it also happens to be
a bookdown book itself.
So you can see that
we have a website here
that looks a little bit
different than the R Markdown
and Distill sites that
Desiree just showed us.
Instead of having
that top navigation
bar that allowed us
to navigate and find
the different pages
in our site, now we
have this table of contents
over here in this left sidebar.
So when I click on that
little hamburger menu,
I can see my table of
contents going up and down,
and I can scroll it.
It's a very long
table of contents,
but you can see that I have
a lot of materials in here,
and I can click around
to any of these.
And you can see
that the right pane
shows me the content of
that page as I click around.
So here, in a bookdown
book, each of these chapters
is actually an R Markdown file.
And when I click on it, I'm
able to see the content,
but I can still access the
entire table of contents here.
And you can imagine that if you
have this many documents in a R
Markdown or Distill
site, you would
have had to build
them, usually manually,
into some kind of
top navigation bar.
And you just don't have
that much real estate
going across the top as you
do with this kind of layout.
So that's one of the
reasons that bookdown is
really popular for educators.
bookdown also comes
with search built in,
so you're able to
search the entire book.
So this is also
another nice feature
that allows you to
leverage your content.
So here's an example of a
much shorter bookdown book
that I built to show
you for a demonstration.
So we can give you a quick tour
of the files that go into it.
So this book has three
labs from a course
I taught on data visualization.
The first one is about Nathan's
Hot Dog Eating Contests.
The second one is the one
that Desiree just showed you,
the MoMA museum tour.
And the third one
was a lesson teaching
about colors with
ggplot, using data
about children's production
of animal sounds.
So the files in this book
project here are on the left.
So you can see that I have
a few R Markdown files.
I have a YAML file.
It's an R project.
I have some folders.
And I have a very important
folder called _book.
Now, Desiree, do you
happen to remember
what the output folder was for
R Markdown and Distill sites?
DESIREE DE LEON: Yes, I do.
It was _site.
ALISON HILL: Yes!
So with a bookdown book,
now our book is in _book.
So when I have all of these
files that you see over here
in the left pane, when I
have all those in a directory
for an R project, and I
mouse over to my Build tab,
and I click on that
Build book icon,
it creates a new
folder called _book.
And that's where my
book now lives locally.
So I'm going to show you
inside some of those files.
So let's take a look
first at index.Rmd.
So Desiree described
this as the home page
for your other R Markdown
sites, and it's actually
the home page,
also, for bookdown.
It also happens to turn
into your first chapter.
So if you take a look inside,
it looks pretty familiar.
There is YAML at the top.
We have a title, a
subtitle, an author.
We also have two new
YAML keys on the bottom.
And these are critical for
building a bookdown book.
They are site and output.
So both of those are
necessary for building and H2
in my book like the
one we're building now.
And then the rest of this file,
everything underneath the YAML,
can be a regular
R Markdown file.
It just also happens
to turn into chapter 1.
So like with our
other sites, we also
have a separate
[INAUDIBLE] file, too.
So in the [INAUDIBLE] R Markdown
and Distill sites that Desiree
demonstrated, you
had a _site.yml file.
And in bookdown, it's
an _bookdown.yml file.
And this file works in concert
with the index.Rmd file
to guide how all of our
chapters [INAUDIBLE] together.
So I'm going to recommend that
your _bookdown.yml file is
pretty sparse.
The main key that I recommend
using for this YAML file
is new_session.
And I recommend that
you set it to true.
This means that each of
your R Markdown chapters
is knit in a separate section.
This will make your life
easier and will make it easier
for you to troubleshoot
when you're knitting
your book, building your book.
Any of the errors
that you see will
be a lot easier to debug
if each of the chapters
is totally independent.
You might notice that
my chapter files here
on the left are now named
with numbers as prefixes.
So I have 01-hotdogs,
02-moma, and 03-meow.
You can use the _bookdown.yml
file to instead list the order
of your R Markdown chapters.
So before, it was using the
number of chapters to determine
the order that the
book got built.
You can also take away
those numbers from the names
of the files and use the
_bookdown.yml to determine
the order of the chapters as
they are presented to you.
So that's another way that
you can use this _bookdown.yml
file.
And the chapters themselves,
I have three of them
here in addition
to the index.Rmd.
Those are each separate
R Markdown files,
but there was one major change.
And that is that each
of these chapters
has to begin with a
level 1 Markdown header.
So here you see hashtag
MoMA Museum Tour.
Each of these chapters
has to start with that.
And so that means that none
of your chapters in a bookdown
book can have its own YAML.
And so this is probably
the biggest problem
if you're going to be
trying to convert existing
material into bookdown.
It means that
you're going to have
to remove the YAML from each
individual R Markdown file that
will go into a chapter.
So each chapter has to start
with a level 1 Markdown header
and can't have its own YAML.
They actually [INAUDIBLE]
the YAML from the index.Rmd.
And so this gives
you a little bit
of an overview of what
bookdown is doing.
So what you make is, you make
these separate R Markdown
files for each chapter.
So here we have index.Rmd,
And then another Rmd,
and another Rmd.
And each of those begins with
that level 1 chapter heading.
So those are all your
separate R Markdown files.
And remember that index.Rmd
is the special one that
also includes a YAML.
[INAUDIBLE] bookdown does
when you have this new_session
true--
[AUDIO OUT]
--in the bookdown YAML is that
it knits of these R Markdown
files in--
[AUDIO OUT]
--page.
So each of those
is now independent.
But how do we get
to the point where
we're seeing them all together?
book down merges
them and gives us
the nice, interactive
online navigable
book that we see when
we build the book.
So how do we share the
book once it's actually
written and built?
We know our HTML files
live in that _book folder.
So this should seem
like old hat to you now.
What I would do is go
to app.netlify.com/drop,
and I [INAUDIBLE] I can drop
that _book folder into the same
spot.
And that would give me a link.
But you might have noticed that
some of those random domain
names are hard to remember
and keep track of.
I believe the one
that Desiree was
working with was called
hardcore-goldwasser.
It's good for flying
under the radar,
but they're probably
not great for learners,
and they're probably not
easy for you to share.
So we can update the
domain on netlify.com
to make the link easier to
share with other people.
So in this example, our random
domain was stoic-babbage.
So if you go into the
Deploys tab on Netlify
once you've made
your account, you
can see that that's
my default subdomain.
And if I click on
Options, Edit Site Name,
then I can change it.
So here I'm going to
change it to dataviz-book,
which amazingly was not taken.
So now I have the domain
dataviz-book.netlify.com.
And you can see
it takes a second,
but it is already deployed.
The new link works right away.
And now, because I have
an account with Netlify
and I've changed that domain,
that's my domain forever.
I can keep that.
And I can always
update that as well,
the way we showed you earlier.
So the best part
about bookdown is
that I think it's hard to
get lost in a bookdown book.
It's [INAUDIBLE]
default. You think
it's going to be
long, because you
have this big table of
contents in the left side.
So that works in your favor.
People are used to being able
to scroll up and down vertically
in that table of contents.
And the search
functions help as well.
And so since you
have more real estate
in the table of
contents vertically,
you can also add a
lot more content then.
So it may be easier when
you have longer-form content
for teaching, as opposed
to an R Markdown site
or a Distill site, where you
have to manually build up
that site navigation.
The hard parts of bookdown
are that if you're
converting existing R Markdown
files over to this new format,
you're going to
have to do some work
to be able to remove those
YAMLs from your individual files
and start them all with those
level 1 chapter headers.
You may also need to
rename your files.
And you also still don't
get to have subfolders.
So you're still going to
have all your R Markdown
files in one directory.
And so once you get a
certain number of these,
it can pretty quickly
feel fairly messy.
So, Desiree, we have made it to
the summit, which is blogdown.
DESIREE DE LEON: We have!
Yes.
Hooray!
ALISON HILL: So blogdown
is a great package
for building custom and unique
websites with R Markdown,
but it is not for
the faint of heart.
It is also probably not
the best choice for you
to adopt on complete
short notice,
because there is a lot to learn.
But I wanted to make sure that
you know about it, in case
you've already tried the
tools that we've just covered.
So if you've already tried R
Markdown sites, Distill sites,
or bookdown, and you're
still not quite satisfied
with the options and you want
something highly customizable,
then you may [INAUDIBLE]
[? look up ?] blogdown.
Or for other folks who have a
little bit more time to prep,
if you're looking at a
fall or winter quarter
class for next year,
you could think
about making a website
using blogdown.
So what is blogdown?
It's an R package that helps
you build a website using
a generator called Hugo.
And the package itself
lets you use the RStudio
IDE to build your site and to
use R Markdown content to make
your site.
So one of the best and
worst things about Hugo
is that you now have access
to over 100 Hugo themes
to choose from.
So you can get really
creative with it.
So you may have felt like when
you were looking at bookdown
sites or Distill or
R Markdown sites--
you've probably
seen a lot of sites
that look just like those.
And there's some
benefits to that.
I don't think there's anything
wrong with using a default
site.
But a lot of people want
to go a little bit further,
and they have
specialized needs that
require specialized solutions.
But it's also easy to
get very overwhelmed
by the choices of Hugo themes.
So for my own course
websites and when I teach,
my favorite thing to use
is the Hugo Academic theme,
because it is very
well documented,
and it's very flexible, also.
The theme also has built-in
search, which is really nice.
So here is the documentation
theme for Academic.
It's a demonstration site.
You can see that I have a little
search button up at the top.
And you can see that
there's all kinds
of different content in here.
And it's important to
remember with Hugo sites,
when you look at a
demonstration site,
it's trying to show
you everything.
It's not necessarily
showing you the best way
to lay out everything.
So I built a demonstration
site for this webinar
using the Hugo Academic
theme and porting over
my existing content
from the course I taught
on data visualization,
where I had that R Markdown
site that Desiree actually
showed at the very beginning.
So I converted all of that
content over to blogdown
to show you what's possible.
So here is my blogdown site.
And you can access it at
share-blogdown.netlify.com.
And you can see I have
my nice built-in search.
I have this top nav bar.
And you can see I have some
nice features, like being
able to link to my
RStudio Cloud, perhaps,
or my Piazza, GitHub.
You can put all those
links in one place.
You can also see that I
have some interesting ways
to lay out content that are
a little bit more varied
than what we had at our
fingertips with R Markdown,
Distill, and bookdown sites.
Here, I've also used blog
posts to lay out a schedule.
And this was inspired by
[INAUDIBLE] course website.
So showing you each of the labs
stacked on top of each other.
Where you click on--
[AUDIO OUT]
--virtual lab, the
content for that lab.
You can also see a course
section for the syllabus,
and finally some instructors
with pictures, links,
all of the things.
There's also a
Resources section here
that shows a different
kind of layout,
where you can share different
materials with users.
Just another different
option that's
available with the
Hugo Academic theme.
So here, if you remember,
I showed you this schedule.
And if I clicked on this Lab
02, the MoMA Museum Tour,
that's actually the lab that
Desiree started with initially.
So let me show you
what that looks like.
You would go to
that page, and you
would see these two [INAUDIBLE]
here, Lab and [INAUDIBLE]..
And what each of those
goes to is actually,
the lab goes to an
R Markdown site.
So this is housed
within my blogdown site,
but I didn't have to change
anything about that file.
I literally just copied
and pasted it over
into a directory in
my blogdown site.
And then I also used [INAUDIBLE]
slides to make my presentation
slides in R Markdown.
So you can see
that I also copied
and pasted those directly
from my R Markdown
site and directory
in my blogdown site.
And then this allows me to take
advantage of one of the best
benefits of using
blogdown for teaching,
which is that when I use
the add-in to build my site,
so I use the blogdown
add-in Serve Site,
it creates a folder
called _public.
And that's the
website that I see.
But what it also does
under the hood for me is,
it builds any other kind of R
Markdown content that I have.
So I can house my other
R Markdown HTML documents
in here, as well as
my [INAUDIBLE] slides.
I can do it all,
and I can build it
all with one button,
which is really nice.
So just a quick tour
of some of the files
in a blogdown project.
The content folder
is probably the place
that you'll want to
dig into the most.
Your primary R Markdown
files will live here.
You can also use
plain Markdown files.
The YAML does depend on the
theme that you choose, though.
So this means that you'll need
to change any existing YAML
to adapt to your theme.
And this is also
how you can kind of
get locked into a theme.
So once you choose a theme in
blogdown, it's tough to switch.
Sometimes I also stash and
build other R Markdown documents
in the static folder.
And if you go to the repository
associated with my demo site,
you can see how I did that
to deploy my R Markdown
labs and my [INAUDIBLE] slides.
So that's just a
taste of blogdown,
to give you a flavor for the
things that are possible.
So the good parts of blog
down is that you can finally
now have subfolders.
You can have a content
folder organization
that might help you
if you have a lot
of different things like data,
assignments, labs, slides.
You can also knit anything.
So you can have--
different output
formats are possible.
blogdown's also built
on top of bookdown.
So any of the features that are
present in the bookdown HTML
format are also
possible in blogdown.
The bad things, in my
experience, are Hugo.
Hugo is a new dependency
that we've added all.
The other options that
we've discussed so far,
R Markdown sites,
Distill, and bookdown,
only had an R package
that they depended on.
But now when you
work with blogdown,
you are depending on installing
Hugo, which is a language that
does have different versions.
It requires updates.
There's a bit of
maintenance involved.
There's also a more complex
directory structure ,
so with being able
to have subfolders,
you also gain more
complexity as well.
So I wouldn't
necessarily recommend
this for short notice,
but I do think it's
a nice longer-term solution.
Some general blogdown advice--
I do not recommend that you
update Hugo during your course
if you're using blogdown.
I also do not recommend
that you update your Hugo
theme during your course.
And I also just
generally recommend,
don't update anything
during your course,
based on personal experience.
So how do you share
your blogdown site?
The way you do that is by--
let's see if this play--
is by taking that public folder
and dragging and dropping that
into the app.netlify.com/drop.
You can see that it's
thinking, thinking, thinking,
and I get a very nice
random domain name,
[? nostalgic-brahoomtheta. ?]
So that would probably be tough
for me to remember.
I could use the trick
that we showed earlier
to change that custom
domain name to something
more memorable.
And here's a shortcut
that you can use as well.
So if you go to that
repository that I made,
the share-blogdown repository,
I created a little button called
a Deploy to Netlify button.
Now, this works if you're
logged into GitHub.
So if you're already using
GitHub for version control,
if you click on that
Deploy to Netlify button,
you can see that
what it does is,
it allows you to take the
same site that I'm showing you
in my repository.
You can then link it up
to your Netlify account.
So here, Desiree's showing
logging into her existing
Netlify account.
DESIREE DE LEON:
Existing GitHub account.
ALISON HILL: GitHub account.
Thank you.
And it creates a new
repository in her GitHub
with the exact same
files that I had.
And it automatically
deploys it to Netlify
with all the same settings
that I had created.
So now Desiree has her own
copy of my exact same site.
With one button, she
clicked on the Deploy
to Netlify button
in my repository.
Her site deploy is in progress.
It takes a little while
for Hugo to build the site.
So insert Jeopardy! music
here while it's going.
There we go.
Stoic-snyder is now live.
So she can click on that.
So that's the exact same
site that I just showed you,
but now it's based off
source files in her GitHub
repository deployed to her own
URL in Netlify, stoic-snyder.
And then she can change
that, she can edit the files,
and she can employ
continuous deployment
with Netlify, which is by
connecting your GitHub account
and using GitHub to
store your source files.
You can connect that to
Netlify so that every time you
make a change and
you push to GitHub,
the website can
automatically update.
So this is how I would
really recommend--
if you want to use blogdown,
it's one of the great benefits
without needing to worry
too much about remembering
to update your site.
So if you're familiar with Git
and GitHub for version control,
and you'd like to take a foray
into blogdown I recommend that.
We also listed
some more resources
here at our GitHub
repository for this talk.
It's at rstudio-education.
It's called Sharing
Short Notice.
If you look in the GitHub
issues there as well,
I made a list of a bunch of
different educational websites,
course websites, using
the different tools.
So I've tagged them whether
they use blogdown, R Markdown,
bookdown, et cetera.
So you can see links to
the source deployed version
and to the repository.
So you can see the
source files as well.
So thank you for
joining us today.
We hope we've left
you with some ideas
that you can use now
and hopefully later.
And we hope we've left you
with visions of awesome course
websites that you can
make in the future,
dancing in your head.
So we're happy to take
some questions now.
Hi, Peter.
Will you have
explanations for how
to use iframes to incorporate
learner exercises.
That is a very good question.
Desiree, I believe
that you are though
the world's expert
in using iframes
to incorporate learner exercises
into static HTML websites.
DESIREE DE LEON: Yeah, so I
have a blog post that walks you
through how to do that.
It's a little bit involved.
Not terribly, but
it does involve
using a little bit of
JavaScript and some CSS.
But in the blog post--
so you can go to my blog.
It's desiree.rbind.io.
And anyway, that
post will walk you
through the little lines
of JavaScript and CSS
that you need to
get up and running.
And that's something
that I've tried
using in R Markdown sites.
I haven't yet
tried incorporating
LearnR windows, for
example, in [INAUDIBLE]
slides or anything like that.
But it should work in R
Markdown, Distill, blogdown
as well.
So I would point
you to the blog post
there if you want
to get started.
ALISON HILL: Putting
the link in there.
I think if I can see--
I think that's how I send to All
I might have responded to that.
OK, so sorry, everyone.
We're also learning a
new tech stack today.
DESIREE DE LEON: Yes.
Go to Webinar.
ALISON HILL: [LAUGHS] Yes.
So a teaching question--
oh, Desiree, you
know the answer to this one.
How do you make
these great videos?
Such a simple way to
show the code process
without live coding.
DESIREE DE LEON:
Yeah, so the videos--
we used the app Kap,
K-A-P. And it just
works really, really nice.
It gives you the
option of outputting
either as an mp4
file or as a GIF.
So you have those two options.
And actually, out of
those two options,
I really recommend that you
use an MP4 file, because those
are much smaller
files than GIFs,
and it won't weigh
down your site as much.
And then you can just embed
those into any R Markdown
file using a video tag.
ALISON HILL: And I think one
other thing that you did,
Desiree, was you
also made sure that
in the accessibility
settings of your computer,
you made your cursor quite
large for doing those videos.
DESIREE DE LEON: Right.
Yeah, that was within
my operating system.
I just ramped up the size of my
cursor, which is really great.
And then within the
app Kap, there's
a preference setting where
you can click Make My Clicks
Visible or something like that.
So that's what highlights
any time that you click.
That's also really nice
for tutorial videos.
ALISON HILL: That's a
really good question, too,
that we can work up with
screenshots and with videos.
We can work up a blog post for
[? this ?] occasion or RStudio
blog to show how to make
those kinds of videos,
because I do really like them.
Someone has a question
about-- suppose
I want to modify the
generated HTML file and keep
these changes when I knit later.
Is it possible to do so?
Not really.
I think my general answer is,
all of the output directories
that we showed you here today--
every time you
rebuild your site,
they're going to get
overwritten every time.
So if you wanted to have
some HTML that you wanted
to carry through,
you can actually
use raw HTML in your
Rmd source files
and have them translate into
the generated HTML file.
But in general, I
wouldn't recommend
editing any of the output
directories that we showed.
So for an R Markdown
or an Distill site,
that _site folder,
bookdown, that _book folder,
and for blogdown, it
was the _public folder--
I would never recommend editing
by hand any of those files,
because anytime you want
to update your content,
those are going to
get rewritten for you.
Is that accurate according to
what you think, Desiree, also?
DESIREE DE LEON: Absolutely.
Yeah, don't touch
anything in those folders,
because it will mostly
be a waste of your time.
As soon as you knit,
it will all wash away.
But yeah, putting raw HTML into
the R Markdown file itself--
that works just great, and
actually I do that a lot.
ALISON HILL: Let's see.
I actually do not
know the question,
can we interface Rmd files
with Jupyter Notebook.
I do not know the
answer to that,
but that's a really
good question
that we can follow
up on Community with.
We'll chase down
the answer to that.
DESIREE DE LEON: I also don't
know the answer to that.
ALISON HILL: Let's see.
I think I've walked
through the question--
DESIREE DE LEON: How
about this [INAUDIBLE]??
Did we answer this one?
Do you prefer to host
the site on Netlify
for any specific reason?
Are there any
advantages over GitHub?
ALISON HILL: Oh, I don't
see that question at all.
Thank you.
Desiree, do you want to offer
first, or do you want me to?
DESIREE DE LEON: I'll
answer the first part, which
I guess, Netlify, because of
this drag and drop feature,
makes it really, really nice.
I think GitHub can
sometimes be intimidating.
It was for me when
I first started.
So being able to deploy
a website without having
to understand GitHub or
Git is a really nice win,
especially you're doing
stuff on short notice.
So you can answer
the rest, Allison.
ALISON HILL: Yeah.
And for myself, I
use GitHub frequently
for education purposes.
And so I will say that
I switch back and forth.
Sometimes I deploy
sites via Netlify.
sometimes I use GitHub pages.
It largely depends for me on the
kind of project I'm working on
and what kind of link I want
to be able to link out to
and how much I'm updating it.
So I tend to defer
to Netlify, mostly
because I have a
lot of sites there,
and it's a nicer
interface for me and.
The majority of my
sites are blogdown,
and blogdown has a
nice feature, or Hugo
has a nice feature
that's actually,
Netlify can build
Hugo sites for you.
So when you serve your
site locally in RStudio,
what you're essentially doing
is knitting all of your source
files into HTML
or Markdown files,
and then Netlify can
build your site for you.
So it's nice, because I'm
able to outsource that,
and that also allows me
to be able to use GitHub
throughout my workflow a little
bit easier with blogdown.
But with the other options,
I think I go back and forth.
I do tend to use
Netlify more, but I
wouldn't say it's a
completely strong preference.
So Desiree, you
seem like you can
see more questions than I can.
DESIREE DE LEON: Yeah, I
think I must be able to--
ALISON HILL: If you want
to read out any other ones,
I only see three.
DESIREE DE LEON: OK,
here's another question.
I created index.Rmd, but the
tab Build Site does not appear.
What d I have to do?
ALISON HILL: Restart RStudio.
So sometimes it might not yet
detect all the files in there
for it to identify that it needs
to show you that Build Book
or Build Site button.
So restart RStudio, open
that R project file again,
and you should
see that populate.
DESIREE DE LEON: OK, great.
Why does signing up to Netlify
using a version control account
make your life easier?
ALISON HILL: It makes
your life easier
if you use GitHub already.
If you don't use
GitHub already, then it
may not make much of
a difference to you.
But the reason why I
say that is because you
can keep your files that
are already in GitHub
and have Netlify
connect to those.
So whenever you make
a change locally
on your computer
to your website,
you build your site
locally, you can see it.
You push to GitHub,
and then that's
all you have to
remember to do is,
you just have to push
it to, GitHub and you
don't have to do any extra step
to actually deploy or publish
your site.
So the way we showed you
today in this webinar
was a very manual way.
It's not a bad way, but
it's a very manual way
of dragging and dropping
physically that folder
into Netlify, to both
deploy it the first time
and to update it.
And so that could wear
on you after a bit
if you're updating frequently.
If you have a site
that's just kind of done,
and you want to share it, then
that's not really a big deal.
But if you're updating
and maybe adding
materials every couple
days or every week,
you may want to
think about starting
to use version control.
But we didn't want
to necessarily depend
on that for this workshop,
because we wanted to make sure
that we optimized for being able
to share on short notice, which
for me does not involve GitHub.
[LAUGHS]
DESIREE DE LEON: Agreed.
OK, here's another question.
I actually don't know
the answer to this one.
It is, what if I
would prefer not
to use Netlify but a university
server to store my material?
ALISON HILL: Oh, yeah.
You can do that as well.
I did that [INAUDIBLE].
All you really need to know
is know the output directory,
right, Desiree?
As long as you can drag and drop
or place that somewhere, then
you've got a hosted website.
DESIREE DE LEON:
Yeah, as soon as
you have those HTML
files in some place,
then you can use
whatever server you want,
following the instructions
of whatever that server uses.
ALISON HILL: But that's
why it's really nice
to know where the site actually
is, because your source
files are in your project
folder, but knowing where
the actual website lives
and the directory is nice,
because that's the
only folder that you
need to be able to share.
DESIREE DE LEON: Yes.
OK, there are quite a
few other questions here.
Let's see.
ALISON HILL: [INAUDIBLE]
any questions?
MAN: Yes.
If you wouldn't mind, just
to be done on the hour,
maybe we could transition
some of the questions
to RStudio Community, or maybe
an article on the education
website's blog?
ALISON HILL: Oh, yeah.
MAN: I don't think I've ever
seen this many questions,
so there's definitely
a lot of interest
and a lot of curiosity.
So I'll be sure to
get those to you--
ALISON HILL: OK, great.
MAN: --as quickly as possible.
DESIREE DE LEON: Sounds good.
MAN: So thank you
for the webinar.
I would like to say
to the audience,
a few people
reported some audio--
ALISON HILL: Oh, no.
MAN: --and some
visual issues, yeah.
But it's not a problem.
We recorded the webinar,
and we'll post it
to the
rstudio.resources.com/webinars,
as well as email everyone who
registered for the webinar,
so everyone will be able
to see the recording.
As well as, I just posted an
RStudio Community discussion
thread to continue discussion.
And I've been collecting
a lot of the links
that you mentioned
as well, so people
will be able to see some of
those resources you referred
to as well.
ALISON HILL: Great.
DESIREE DE LEON: Awesome.
MAN: I'd love to give you
an opportunity to tie up,
and then it's right on the
hour for when people are
looking to leave the webinar.
ALISON HILL: OK, great.
Well, I will go back in the
slides so everybody can see.
Here is where the repository is.
So github.com/rstudio
education/sharing short notice.
So this is where our
slides actually are.
So if you want to go there,
you can see our slides.
Our slide files, all the videos,
all the images from this talk
are in there.
And then if you go to the GitHub
issues there in that repository
as well, you'll see
some more examples
where I've linked
to the source code
and deployed
versions of websites.
So you can hopefully
get inspired.
DESIREE DE LEON: Yeah, there
are a lot of great ideas there.
And we hope that this
has been useful for you
and inspires you to try
some websites on your own
if you've been intimidated
by that previously.
And we hope that this makes
building course websites
on short notice a
little less painful.
Thanks, everyone.
ALISON HILL: Thank you.
[RSTUDIO SOUND]